Seen this couple quiz all over our for you page,
so we're gonna attempt to do it.
Lucky's gonna have headphones on,
I'm gonna answer the questions, and then we're gonna swap.
My favourite colour is either black or white.
Lucky's favourite colour is blue and green.
I'm gonna put headphones on.
Okay, so my favorite colors are blue and green
and Nora's favorite colors are black and white.
And my favorite food is hot wings and steak and fries.
Or a good cheeseburger.
It's. It depends on the day.
And Nora's favorite food is
Thai food is a really good one.
My favorite food is probably Thai food.
Thai food or pasta, depending on what mood I'm in.
Lucky's favorite food is wings right now.
Usually a burger or steak and fries
since we're already talking about food.
My favorite drink is probably a really good mocktail. Or ginger ale.
And I think Lucky's favorite drink.
It always kind of changes,
but I think it's a ginger beer right now.
Give me Hendrix!
My favorite drink is a ginger beer
and Nora's favorite drink is ginger ale. Or a mocktail.
My favorite vacation
we've taken together was going to Tulum for Nora's birthday
I think like two years ago,
and I'm pretty sure her favorite vacation is the same.
We've gone on so many vacations together,
but I would have to say it's the birthday trip lucky surprised me on.
For my 20th birthday we went to Tulum.
I Was pregnant with slim. And then or our honeymoon.
My lucky number is probably seven.
Lucky's lucky number is thirteen.
My lucky number.
Our favorite number is 13 and Nara's is 7.
Favorite movie is The Breakfast Club.
And Nara's favorite movie is
Harry Potter, I think. My favorite movie is Harry Potter.
It's always been I had to test our houses when we got married.
He's Slytherin, obviously,
and I'm Gryffindor.
And then his favourite movie I think is The Breakfast Club,
but he likes older movies in general.
And then last but not least, TV shows.
We don't really watch a lot of TV shows lately,
so I don't even know what his favourite one would.
Probably some survival show.
And then mine is Grey's anatomy.
I've watched it for the past ten years.
My favourite TV show is probably the office.
He can't beat that show.
And Nara's favorite TV show is Grey's anatomy.